mr speaker after six years i can mention
azalean zagari ratcliffe in the chamber
and not beg for her release so thank you
mr speaker after eight urgent questions
and countless debates it's a pleasure to
finally be standing here and talking
about her and this wouldn't have
happened without the foreign secretary
and a member for braintree so can i say
thank you from the bottom of my heart
and to all the fcu officials who i know
worked tirelessly to make this happen so
thank you
i also wanted to thank redress gibson
dunn change uk and amnesty international
and other organizations and individuals
who worked so hard to release nasalin
and can i thank all the mps on behalf of
richard radcliff who texted me just
before i stood up to say thank you
across the chamber because whichever
side of the house you were in you worked
hard
everyone worked hard to make sure that
nasalin was released so whichever party
whichever member wherever whichever
constituency you represented thank you
and thank you from richard radcliffe as
well including all the mps who visited
richard when he was on both his hunger
strikes
and to the community especially in west
hampstead where naslin's home is thank
you for always coming and supporting us
but most importantly i want to pay
tribute to my constituent richard
radcliffe
for his relentless campaigning but i
also think he's really set the bar high
for all husbands
[Laughter]
can i say
to nazanin welcome home after six long
years and can i say to gabriella this
time mommy really is coming home